now let's discuss about the other
program which is genomic data analysis
so whether you are just starting your
journey or looking to expand your
expertise this program is designed to
provide you with the skills and the
knowledge that is needed to excel in
this rapidly evolving field of genomics
so there are three different levels of
the program that I'll take you through
when I go through the program pages of
these programs but to talk about the
topics I'll divide them up into beginner
intermediate and advanced level so at
the beginner level you will develop a
strong Foundation exploring
bioinformatics and also understanding
Next Generation sequencing data
exploration and also you will learn
about sequence alignment and more so
when we talk about sequence alignment
from there I get this picture of the
workflow that is very important for us
to understand so we have the sequencing
reads we need to understand uh how to
take it up for quality control and then
uh we align them up and after align
aligning them on the reference genome we
want to understand how we look for these
specific variants and then finally
understand what these variants actually
are or what type of variance these
actually are so we need to annotate them
what are the different types of files
that are included at all of these
different steps and what all of these
different steps includes and how do you
get to know about a specific type of
variant annotated effectively is what
the program is all about so at the
intermediate level it will we will take
you deep into the Intriguing topics such
as variant calling we'll process the
weekend pipeline we look at the results
we'll try to interpret these biological
insights out of the results that we get
and we'll also discuss about
can you take care of this someone is
requesting to record the meeting locally
uh we can share the recording of the
session with you uh distance sorry if I
am pronouncing your name uh not
correctly we are also live on YouTube so
you have a link from there I'll deny a
request at the moment thank you
all right so from the variant calling
we'll also learn about copy number
variation analysis machine learning
genome white Association studies and
also briefly touch upon the ethical
considerations and for those seeking
Advanced knowledge we'll delve into
population genetics DNS sequence
analysis VCF file analysis functional
annotation and also we'll discuss about
these real life case studies on sarskov
to breast cancer oncogene variant
calling and also Ebola
and by joining this program you will
gain practical hands-on experience learn
cutting a Cutting Edge techniques and
also unravel the Mysteries that are
hidden within the genomic data so be
prepared to unlock a world of exciting
possibilities and make significant
contribution in the field of genomic
data analysis